esta semana se conocieron las
nominaciones a los premios Oscar la
película con más postulaciones es
Everything everywhere olat One que
cuenta con 11 mientras que the banshees
of and sheeran y La alemana All the
Western Front tienen nueve una buena
noticia para América Latina es que
Argentina 1985 aspira a la mejor
película internacional los premios se
entregarán el 12 de marzo en Los Ángeles
pero para entender un poco más nos
acompaña desde Ciudad de México Eduardo
Gutiérrez él es editor de la revista
quien en México Eduardo Gracias por
acompañarnos esta mañana aquí en directo
América de France 24 cuéntenos a usted
qué le sorprendió de las nominaciones y
que sí se esperaba por ejemplo como el
éxito de Everything everywhere all at
One
Cómo estás Muy buenos días Qué gusto
saludarte a ti y a todo tu auditorio
Pues sí han sido muy sorpresivas estas
nominaciones realmente porque bueno
hemos visto como la academia se está
acercando precisamente y no sé A ti qué
te parece a este rubro más comercial
ahora vemos como break por ejemplo con
Tom Cruise alcanzado esta nominación
algo que no hubiera sucedido en otros
años lo cual es también bastante
interesante y bueno esta favorita
también habla un poco de la inclusión
que se está tratando de hacer en la
academia luego de Pues ya sabes tanto
reclamos que se ha tenido a lo largo de
la historia de la entrega de los premios
y bueno esta película que tiene además
un elenco completamente asiático
realmente pues es una sorpresa para
muchos pero es una película que sin
lugar a dudas ha probado su valía y que
tiene esta posibilidad de mostrarnos un
poco más acerca de la ciencia ficción de
este género que le habla tanto a la
gente y con la que la gente conecta
también pero desde un punto diferente
vamos no es Marvel aunque también se ha
logrado ya a lo largo de las
postulaciones ver cómo este tipo de de
películas por ejemplo
y de muchas otras cintas insisto
volvemos a la parte de Top Gun Maverick
que se están acercando a esta parte de
que la gente quiere ver las películas
que va a ver el cine Bueno pues
premiadas por la academia entonces Creo
que estas nominaciones nos han
sorprendido En ese sentido y también un
poco hablando de esta parte de la
inclusión Pues bueno nos sorprenden una
vez más se están dando avances Quizá en
esto en incluir películas que antes no
fueran consideradas y bueno una vez más
otro año en el que no hay directoras
mujeres presentes en la terna para esta
categoría lo cual seguramente va a
levantar muchas cejas y que una vez más
van a tener Pues que tratar de resolver
para el próximo año Edward aquí usted me
preguntó yo Considero que los Oscar
Siempre han estado si bien no tan
cercanos a esa parte comercial como
ahora tampoco han estado del todo
alejado sino es que hayan premiado
exclusivamente al cine independiente
usted me corregirá si es así o no
sino realmente hemos visto también a lo
largo de la entrega de los premios Bueno
pues empezó con una ceremonia que duraba
15 minutos ahora dura más de tres horas
y sí acercándose un poco más a lo
comercial por ejemplo este año Jimmy que
es un hombre que realmente le habla
mucho a las audiencias que tiene retos y
récords muy importantes en la televisión
pues bueno ha sido convocado para que él
lleve este año la ceremonia Entonces eso
habla también un poco de esta necesidad
que tiene la academia de acercarse al
Gran público que es al final de cuentas
para el que está dirigido Hollywood en
general entonces realmente sí hemos
visto como se han premiado Cintas en
particular bélicas por ejemplo en cuanto
al rubro de la acción han sido estas
películas que retratan la guerra en
Muchas de sus facetas hay películas
nominadas este año que también lo hacen
en el rubro por ejemplo de cortometrajes
y de y de este tipo de documentales Pues
bueno hay una en particular que retrata
el conflicto que se está viviendo
actualmente en Ucrania que es también
algo a lo que la academia recurre mucho
y precisamente hablando de lo que la
academia utiliza
en la historia de manera consecutiva es
las personas afro la Segunda Guerra
Mundial suelen ser temas que siempre se
premian y por el contrario no se suelen
premiar las películas que salen en
plataformas como Netflix o Amazon Prime
esta vez cómo es esa relación entre los
temas de siempre y las plataformas
diferentes
hay que hablar un poco también en este
ponerlo un poco de contexto a la gente
no se premia tanto a las plataformas Por
qué Porque lo que está buscando también
la academia es mantener a las personas
en las salas de cine al final de cuentas
no se nos puede olvidar el cine si es un
arte pero también se ha convertido en un
negocio y el negocio es precisamente
llevar a la gente a las salas de cine
que estén ahí consuman Que disfruten
además también las películas están
hechas para ser vistas en pantalla
grande con sonido
por ejemplo Avatar ahora también no en
un reto muy interesante de de efectos
especiales es para verla en la gran
pantalla qué pasa con las películas que
se estrenan en las plataformas Pues
bueno además que eso no significa un
negocio para para Hollywood en general
sino más bien para las plataformas que
las lanzan Pues bueno es también por eso
que se han establecido ciertos cánones
que ahora se están utilizando como el
hecho de que las películas que quieran
ser nominadas al Oscar tienen que tener
un estreno comercial por lo menos en
algunas salas de cine Como lo hemos
visto que sucedió con Pinocho en Estados
Unidos hacer este tipo de campañas que
sean continuas para que la gente de la
academia pueda estar viendo las
películas para que la gente sepa
precisamente de qué tratan las películas
vemos ahora en la pantalla esta película
de nuestro queridísimo compatriota
Guillermo del Toro que sin lugar a dudas
es de las más fuertes en cuanto
animación se refiere este año y que
seguramente auguramos ya se va a llevar
el Oscar entonces bueno justo es esto se
estrenó en Netflix pero también tuvo que
buscar una salida comercial este es como
el acuerdo que se tuvo con la academia
quieres estar nominado bueno pues se
encuentra que tus películas tengan
además de la presencia en la plataforma
sí también la presencia en los cines
comerciales y hablando de la presencia
latinoamericana en los Oscar como usted
ya mencionó a Guillermo del Toro con
Pinocho Le quiero preguntar por
Argentina 19 ochenta y cinco qué tantas
opciones cree usted que tiene de ganarse
la mejor película internacional este año
es una película bastante interesante
tiene la verdad una fuerte competencia
Sin lugar a dudas pero bueno volvemos a
esta este punto no son los temas que a
la academia le gusta abordar son los
temas que que realmente son digamos los
así las asignaturas pendientes que tiene
el mundo son temas que a la academia le
gustan muchísimo ya lo decías tú los
afroamericanos en el caso de la
esclavitud con Estados Unidos la Segunda
Guerra Mundial en el caso de las bombas
de Hiroshima y nagasaki vamos son
asignaturas pendientes que tiene Estados
Unidos pero que también son temas que
son asignaturas pendientes en el mundo
las que tienen fuerte posibilidad de
llevarse una estatuilla Porque además es
hasta cierto punto una especie de
redimirse con todas estas no deudas que
tenemos con el pasado y en ese sentido
Argentina La verdad es que 1985 tiene
una gran posibilidad y bien insisto
tiene una una competencia fuerte creo
que nos podría dar una sorpresa no
quisiera adelantar mucho en este sentido
Pero claro es además una película muy
bien lograda que hace un retrato
bastante de lo que sucedió entonces pues
Bueno realmente tenemos por ahí esta
esta candidatura y especial para para
latinoamérica y en el caso también de
los mexicanos muy en particular pues la
presencia también por ahí el mejor
fotografía ahí de Alejandro González
iñárrito con su película bardo y bueno
también ahí como productor coproductor
de Alfonso para una vez más entonces
pues sí latinoamérica sigue Pisando
fuerte en la academia estadounidense